Profª. Tamar Gendler: Então,
temos bastante matéria
na aula de hoje, mas 2 coisas
principais estão na programação.
A 1ª é terminar a discussão
sobre os pontos de vista
de Aristóteles sobre a
felicidade e harmonia;
e a 2ª é apresentar a vocês o
tema da alma desordenada.
E na parte final da aula, vamos
usar os nossos clickers.
Por isso, certifiquem-se de tê-los à
mão para daqui... não sei...
8 minutos mais ou menos.
Então, como vocês se lembram,
na última aula falamos
sobre essa ideia antiga de que há um
certo tipo de prosperidade
disponível para os seres humanos.
Um certo tipo de prosperidade
que os gregos chamavam de eudaimonia,
disponível para as pessoas
cujas almas exibem
um certo tipo de harmonia.
E vocês se lembram da imagem
articulada por Platão
e assumida em muitos
aspectos por Aristóteles,
em que temos a razão, a racionalidade.
Temos o espírito, um conjunto de
emoções que está preocupado
com coisas como a honra.
E temos o apetite, que está
preocupado com coisas
como o consumo de alimentos,
a procriação que permite a
continuação da nossa espécie
e a procriação por uma
vontade de procriar.
E que a pessoa que está numa
posição de prosperar ou florescer
é a pessoa cujos instintos no
domínio do apetite
e no domínio das emoções
estão alinhados com os seus
compromissos reflexivos.
Ou seja, alguém que age automaticamente
do modo que gostaria de
agir reflexivamente.
A pessoa que
instintivamente se senta e
lê
quando ela está
empenhada em fazer isso.
A pessoa que instintivamente
evita o bolo de chocolate
quando é apresentada a ele,
se é isso que ela está
empenhada em fazer.
Então, o que Aristóteles
tentou fazer no segmento
da Ética a Nicômaco é fornecer uma
fórmula, uma estratégia,
um método para chegar ao ponto de
ter a nossa alma em ordem.
E só para lembrá-los onde isso se
encaixa no contexto da argumentação,
Aristóteles afirma que há
um tipo de coisa
que nós buscamos por nós mesmos,
e é exatamente a coisa que
eu acabei de referir.
É a prosperidade ou eudaimonia.
É este sentimento de que
se está vivendo
de acordo com o melhor que pode ser.
E Aristóteles ressalta
que o tipo de prosperidade que
estamos interessados ??aqui
não é a gratificação que vem
a partir da satisfação do apetite.
Não é a gratificação que
vem de satisfazer
as demandas que a honra, ou
espírito, nos dão.
Trata-se da gratificação que vem
de fazer uso da nossa capacidade
como seres reflexivos.
E, para isso, vocês têm o
argumento do final da última aula
que para cada objeto existe
algo especial nele,
algo ao qual ele apresenta propriedades
que o resto dos objetos no
mundo não apresentam.
E a função especial de um ser
humano, diz Aristóteles,
é a expressão da razão: "A atividade
da alma que expressa a razão",
numa das traduções padrão.
Assim, o bem humano na
imagem aristotélica
é a coisa sobre os seres
humanos que os diferencia
de outros tipos de seres.
Os outros tipos de seres têm
os tipos de apetites
que descrevemos.
Na verdade, quase todos os seres
biológicos parecem ter
algo parecido com o que Platão chamaria
de uma parte apetitiva da alma.
E parece que um número de
animais não-humanos
também têm o que Platão e
Aristóteles chamaria
de parte espiritual da alma, pelo
menos em alguns aspectos.
Eles têm ligações emocionais
que parecem se manifestar
no comportamento.
Mas a melhor e mais completa
virtude distintamente humana,
diz Aristóteles, é a capacidade
de se envolver na razão
e a capacidade de se
envolver na reflexão.
E a capacidade, então, de
estruturar a vida de tal forma
que o espírito e o apetite se
alinhem com a razão.
Portanto, a virtude na
imagem de Aristóteles
é a que as suas respostas
instintivas se alinhem
com os seus compromissos reflexivos.
É o que acontece
quando você não está prestando
atenção no seu comportamento,
é o tipo de comportamento que você
olharia para trás e diria:
"Uau, eu me sinto tão bem por
ter ajudado esta criança
em momento de crise".
Ou: "O que eu fiz foi
evitar a tentação
que teria me levado a fazer algo
desaprovado por mim".
A questão que Aristóteles está
preocupado, nas páginas que lemos,
é uma questão sobre com o que
esta virtude se parece
e como esse tipo de virtude
pode ser cultivado.
A virtude, para recordar, é
exatamente a virtude
que Platão chamou de a
virtude da justiça.
É a virtude da existência de um
certo tipo de harmonia
entre o que eles chamam de
partes da alma,
uma harmonia de tal modo
que é possível de ser
endossada reflexivamente.
Eu vou passar relativamente rápido
pelos 2 slides seguintes
porque nós voltaremos a este
assunto sobre Aristóteles
mais 2 vezes nas próximas 3 aulas.
Esta unidade do curso
é uma tentativa de fornecer uma
exposição das ideias de Aristóteles.
Esta é a tentativa número 1 de
apresentá-las a vocês;
vocês terão mais 2.
Aristóteles distingue 2
tipos de virtude:
de pensamento e de caráter.
As virtudes de pensamento são as coisas
que crescem pela instrução
pedagógica simples.
Portanto, é uma virtude de
pensamento saber que 6 vezes 7 é 42.
É uma virtude de pensamento saber
fatos sobre a tabela periódica
ou saber informações particulares
sobre as estruturas
políticas ao seu redor.
Essas são as virtudes de pensamento,
e elas são comunicadas aos outros
e cultivadas nos outros
a partir de um processo de
pedagogia tradicional.
Mas um dos temas cruciais da
tradição filosófica antiga é que,
além de virtudes de pensamento,
há o que Aristóteles chamou de
as virtudes de caráter.
Virtudes de caráter não são as
coisas que você processa
de forma racional
e adquire como resultado do que
alguém explica para você.
São coisas que você processa
nas partes espirituais e
apetitivas da sua alma
como resultado de uma espécie
de cultivo do hábito.
Aristóteles diz que essas
virtudes de caráter
não surgem em nós nem pela natureza
nem contrárias à natureza.
O que ele quer dizer com isso?
Bem, imaginem que eu esteja
tentando que os meus óculos
fiquem no ar ao soltá-los.
Eu teria sucesso?
Eu poderia gratificá-los cada
vez que ficassem no ar
e repreendê-los cada vez que
caíssem no chão.
Não importa quantas
vezes eu tente fazer
que os meus óculos fiquem no
ar, eles vão cair.
É contra a natureza deles.
É impossível alterar a
relação entre os óculos
e a força gravitacional no mundo.
Aristóteles explica o seu
argumento usando uma pedra.
É impossível mudar o
caráter dos óculos.
Por outro lado, se eu pegar
uma semente de abóbora
e colocá-la num pouco de terra,
regá-la e deixá-la no sol,
então, mesmo sem
intervenção da minha
parte,
a semente de abóbora dará
origem a um broto de abóbora
que sairá do solo e se moverá em
direção à luz do sol,
de modo que, eventualmente,
formará uma planta de abóbora.
Portanto, se eu plantar a semente
de abóbora, por natureza,
ela se torna, sem a minha
intervenção, uma planta de
abóbora.
As virtudes de caráter se apoiam entre
o que uma semente de abóbora faz
para uma planta de abóbora
e o faz tentar manter os óculos no ar,
dada a gravidade.
Elas não surgem em nós
nem pela natureza...
não crescem independentemente
de nós, naturalmente,
como a nossa altura ou o nosso cabelo.
São coisas que acontecem
devido ao curso das coisas.
Nem são contrárias à natureza.
Elas não são como um treinamento
para sermos capazes de flutuar no ar,
ficar 72 semanas seguidas sem dormir
ou ficar sem comida por uma década.
Essas seriam as coisas que são
contrárias à natureza.
"Virtudes de caráter não surgem
em nós nem por natureza
nem contrariamente à natureza.
Antes, somos, por natureza,
capazes de adquiri-las.
Elas são coisas para as quais
temos a capacidade.
E elas são aperfeiçoadas em
nós com o hábito.
" Com o que se parece esse
processo de habituação?
Bem, Aristóteles aponta numa das
citações mais famosas
de Ética a Nicômaco que aprendemos
a fazer as coisas fazendo.
"Nós aprendemos um
ofício", diz Aristóteles,
"produzindo o mesmo produto
que devemos produzir
quando tivermos aprendido.
Aprendemos a ser um construtor"...
Como?
Ao ler um livro chamado Como
construir uma casa?
Eu li algo chamado "Como
montar uma mesa"
e o resultado não foi uma mesa.
O que resultou numa mesa foi o
meu filho de 12 anos
– obviamente um construtor
de maneira inata –
que veio e me mostrou
como montar a mesa.
Eu, assim, aprendi a ser
uma construtora.
Eu me tornei uma construtora
praticando a arte de construir.
Eu me tornei uma harpista
praticando a arte de tocar harpa.
Quantos de vocês tocam um
instrumento musical?
Quantos de vocês aprenderam a
tocar um instrumento
lendo um livro chamado Como tocar piano,
mas sem nunca tocar nenhuma tecla?
0?
Quantos de vocês aprenderam a
tocar um instrumento
praticando o instrumento musical?
Quantos de vocês se tornaram um
pianista, harpista ou flautista
tocando piano, harpa ou flauta?
Tudo bem.
Então, o argumento de Aristóteles é
que nós nos tornamos aquilo
que esperamos ser agindo como isso
fosse o que já éramos.
Do mesmo jeito que aprendemos a
tocar piano tocando piano,
aprendemos a ser justos
praticando ações justas.
Aprendemos a ser temperantes,
agindo de forma temperante.
Aprendemos a ser corajosos,
praticando ações corajosas.
O modo que cultivamos os hábitos é,
1º, estruturando conscientemente
as nossas vidas de tal forma que o
hábito que queremos cultivar
se torne parte do
repertório comportamental
e,
depois, praticando uma e outra vez
até que ele não exija mais a
nossa concentração.
É exatamente como qualquer
habilidade adquirida no domínio
da música, no domínio do
esporte, em qualquer domínio...
onde você aprendeu –
primeiro de forma consciente
e depois instintivamente – a praticar
um determinado padrão de
comportamento, executando
o programa descrito por Aristóteles
para o cultivo da virtude.
Voltaremos ao tema novamente
em algumas aulas.
Quero concluir esta seção
mostrando uma das partes
da discussão de
Aristóteles mais famosas.
Portanto, Aristóteles ressalta
que há um perigo aqui.
Há o perigo de aprender a
tocar mal o piano,
porque os hábitos cultivados quando
você deixa os seus dedos
retos em vez de curvados se
enraízam no seu comportamento,
da mesma forma que os bons hábitos.
Não é como se tivéssemos um
mecanismo de filtragem automática
para a prática que diz:
"Só devem ficar os bons hábitos;
os maus hábitos, fora".
Seja o que for que você pratique,
isso se tornará habitual para você.
Essas ações de praticar o que você
pretende se tornar não só são
"as causas e fontes de sua
geração e crescimento"
como "as de seu perecimento".
Praticando a coragem, você
vai se tornar corajoso.
Pratique, no mesmo contexto,
a covardia e ela se incutirá no
seu comportamento habitual
da mesma maneira.
Aristóteles diz que, para
cada um desses estados,
precisamos estar atentos ao fato
de que é possível fazer muito ou
pouco o que objetivamos fazer,
e o ideal é se focar no chamado
meio-termo aristotélico.
As virtudes de Aristóteles, ele diz,
tendem a ser arruinadas pelo
excesso e pela deficiência.
Então, vamos supor que
você seja confrontado
com uma situação de risco.
Existem dois falsos extremos aos quais
você poderia ser atraído.
Você poderia responder a isso
de uma forma covarde
ou de uma forma imprudente.
Entre esses dois extremos,
diz Aristóteles,
encontra-se a virtude da coragem.
Vamos supor que você seja
apresentado a uma situação social.
Você poderia responder com hostilidade.
Você poderia responder
sendo simpático.
Entre eles, diz Aristóteles,
reside a virtude da amizade.
Vamos supor que você seja
esteja numa situação
em que algo é pedido para você.
Você poderia ser mesquinho.
Você poderia ser ostentoso.
Ou poderia ser, na
tradução maravilhosa
que temos, "magnificente"...
que fica entre a mesquinhez
e a ostentação.
Vamos supor que você esteja
estudando para o vestibular
e se depare com uma
situação onde você
pode ser pusilânime... ou vão.
Qual recai entre eles?
Entre eles recai a virtude
da magnanimidade.
Vamos supor que você seja
confrontado com uma situação
em que a possibilidade é ser
autodepreciativo ou prepotente.
Nenhuma é a ideal.
A ideal é a veracidade que se
encontra entre eles.
Vamos supor que você seja
apresentado a uma piada.
Você pode ser sisudo ou bobo.
Ou, em vez disso, você
pode ser espirituoso.
Você pode ser conflituoso.
Você pode ser simpático, mais uma vez,
ou, entre eles, você
pode ser amigável.
Huh. Aquela ali está repetida.
O princípio geral é que
existem 2 extremos no que diz respeito
às virtudes aristotélicas:
um extremo de deficiência e
outro de excesso,
e entre eles está o
meio-termo aristotélico.
Portanto, vocês se lembram
da famosa pintura de Rafael,
A Escola de Atenas, onde
Platão aponta para o céu,
referindo-se à forma, e a
mão de Aristóteles
está no meio do seu corpo,
com a palma virada.
E eu comentei que existem 2
maneiras de interpretá-la.
Uma delas é a rejeição
de Aristóteles
à ideia das formas de Platão;
a outra é que isso, às vezes,
é tido como uma espécie
de articulação encarnada da
ideia do meio-termo.
Então, aqui está, para o
prazer de vocês,
a ideia aristotélica do meio-termo.
Voltaremos a ela em 2 aulas.
Vou concluir esta parte citando a
imagem de Aristóteles
sobre o círculo virtuoso de
formação do hábito.
E, logo depois, é quando vamos
precisar dos nossos clickers...
portanto, se vocês ainda não têm
eles à mão, peguem-os agora.
"Tornamo-nos temperantes –
diz Aristóteles –
abstendo-nos dos prazeres".
E uma vez nos tornamos temperantes,
somos mais capazes de nos
abster de prazer.
É semelhante com a coragem.
O hábito de nos mantermos firmes
em situações assustadoras
nos torna corajosos.
E uma vez que nos tornamos corajosos,
somos mais capazes de nos
mantermos firmes.
Há um círculo para este tipo de
comportamento praticado.
E o que vamos ler nas 3
aulas a partir de agora
é uma articulação
contemporânea dessa ideia
na forma de algo chamado de terapia
cognitivo-comportamental.
OK.
Isso encerra o que começamos na
aula da semana passada.
E eu quero abrir o tópico
que temos para hoje
e percorrê-lo nos nossos
últimos 25 minutos.
Portanto, eu vou dar a moral da
história agora mesmo.
A moral é esta:
Vocês se lembram das páginas
de abertura do Livro II
de A República de Platão,
onde o personagem Glauco
propõe um desafio para o
personagem Sócrates
alegando que se comportar
de forma justa,
de acordo com o próprio
compromisso reflexivo,
de acordo com as normas da moral,
é algo que fazemos apenas por
razões instrumentais.
Não há nada intrinsecamente
valioso para a alma ordenada.
A aula de hoje é sobre 2
histórias incríveis.
Uma, a Ilíada e a Guerra do Vietnã,
analisando os textos de Jonathan Shay;
a outra: os experimentos de
Stanley Milgram,
feitos aqui neste campus na
década de 1960.
Ambas nos abrem uma janela
sobre como se parece
a experiência humana no mundo
sonhado por Glauco.
Glauco disse: O que nós queremos
é poder correr livres,
sem consequências para as
nossas ações.
O que nós queremos é poder
violar as normas da moral.
Dada a oportunidade,
qualquer um faria isso.
As histórias contadas por
Shay e Milgram,
as descrições dadas sobre a
experiência humana
nesses momentos em que a
alma corre louca,
sugerem que talvez Glauco esteja errado.
Sugerem que, por qualquer que seja
a razão, parece haver,
pelo menos nessas áreas,
uma necessidade por parte
dos seres humanos
de um determinado tipo de
estrutura e ordem.
E na ausência desse tipo de
estrutura e ordem,
o mundo parece desmoronar.
No entanto, eu quero começar esta aula
destacando que é um tempo
incomum o que vivemos.
Portanto, vocês podem
responder a esta pergunta?
Pressione 1 se você tiver
servido o exército;
2 se você não tiver
servido o exército,
mas planeja ou espera servi-lo;
e 3 se você não tiver
servido o exército
e nem planeja ou espera servi-lo.
Então, 1 se você prestou
serviço militar,
seja nos EUA ou em outro país do
qual você é cidadão;
2 se o seu plano é, em algum
momento no futuro próximo,
alistar-se no serviço militar;
e 3 se você não pretende fazer isso.
OK.
Vamos dar uma olhada nos números...
Parece que 1% de vocês
serviu o exército.
5% de vocês pretendem fazê-lo
e 94% de vocês não têm expectativas
de se alistar no serviço
militar, nunca.
Próxima pergunta.
Pense na pessoa mais
próxima que você conhece
que esteve no exército
e me digam se é alguém muito próximo,
um irmão ou um melhor amigo.
If so, push one.
Alguém relativamente
próximo, como o seu primo
ou um amigo de escola, alguém
que esteve no seu time,
com quem você se sentia
relativamente próximo.
Ou 3 se a pessoa mais próxima que
você conhece que serviu
o exército foi como um rapaz da
sua escola, um vizinho
ou alguém que você não
conhece muito bem.
E vamos ver os números
que saem desta vez.
OK.
Portanto, quase nenhum de
vocês tem um irmão
ou melhor amigo militar.
Cerca da metade conhece alguém
razoavelmente bem que
está no exército,
e 1/3 de vocês não tem ninguém no
seu círculo social imediato
que realizou o serviço militar.
Vamos voltar uma geração.
Estou perguntando sobre o seu pai,
porque precisamos de ir um em um.
Se eu perguntasse sobre pai e mãe,
estaria dobrando o
conjunto de amostragem.
Então, sobre o seu pai: responda 1
se ele serviu o exército,
2 se ele não serviu.
OK. E vamos ver os números aqui.
Vocês parecem diferentes dos seus pais.
Cerca de 5% de vocês serviram ou
planejam servir o exército.
Cerca de 20% dos seus pais serviram.
Vamos voltar outra geração.
Avô paterno, mais uma vez,
precisamos de apenas uma pessoa.
1 se ele serviu o exército;
2 se ele não serviu.
Avô paterno.
Isso é o pai do seu pai.
Ele serviu o exército?
OK.
54% dos seus avôs serviram o exército.
Então fomos de 5% na
geração de vocês,
20% na geração dos pais
de 55% na geração dos avôs.
Vocês estão vivendo numa época
surpreendentemente incomum.
A distância social entre as
universidades de elite
e as forças armadas dos
EUA é a maior agora
em 200 anos de história do país.
E a arquitetura que temos ao nosso lado
reflete como a experiência
vivida por vocês é incomum.
Quantos de vocês
reconhecem este edifício?
Está a uns 20 metros daqui.
Todas as mãos desta sala
deveriam estar levantadas.
Quantos de vocês já olharam
atentamente para ele?
Este prédio, como alguns
de vocês sabem,
aqueles que são guias de
Yale certamente sabem,
é o Memorial Hall.
Ele foi construído em 1901
sem esta fachada aqui.
E no final da Primeira Guerra Mundial,
durante a qual muita gente
associada a Yale morreu,
este anexo foi construído.
Na parte superior estão os
nomes das batalhas
em que morreram os homens de Yale.
E na parte inferior há
um ataúde vazio:
"Em memória dos homens de Yale que,
fiéis às suas tradições,
deram as suas vidas
para que a liberdade não
pereça na Terra".
A relação de Yale com a Primeira
Guerra Mundial foi extraordinária.
Aqui está um trecho de um discurso
proferido por Henry Simpson
na dedicatória do memorial
que acabei de mostrar.
"Depois da nossa entrada na
guerra, e uma ampla adoção
pelo governo do princípio do
serviço universal,
Yale gradualmente tornou-se um
campo de treinamento militar
e uma universidade
completamente militarizada.
As suas faculdades e laboratórios
moldaram os seus recursos
inteiramente para as artes da guerra
e quase todos os seus estudiosos se
tornaram estudantes membros
das Forças Militares
Organizadas dos Estados Unidos.
Yale manteve uma das escolas
mais importantes de
artilharia da América.
Ela se incumbiu de uma grande
unidade de treinamento naval,
oficiais comissionados para a Marinha.
Ela treinou oficiais para
os corpos do sinal.
Os seus químicos conduziram recursos
para o serviço de guerra química.
Médicos e assistentes foram preparados
para os hospitais do exército
e uma unidade inteira do hospital
do exército na França
foi mantida pela universidade.
Praticamente toda a dinâmica
desta instituição de ensino
foi tirada de forma eficaz na
balança da guerra."
A relação entre as universidades
de elite e os militares
durante a Primeira e Segunda
guerras mundiais foi diferente
de tudo o que qualquer um de
vocês já viu até agora.
E, num esforço para imortalizar
as contribuições para a guerra
feitas pelos homens de Yale,
decidiu-se que seriam gravadas placas
nas paredes interiores do Memorial Hall.
Portanto, se você for
até o refeitório,
do seu lado direito quando você entra,
é possível ver os nomes
dos homens de Yale
que morreram na Guerra Revolucionária.
E, em ambos os lados,
aqueles que morreram nos 2
lados da Guerra Civil,
os nomes dos que morreram na
Guerra Hispano-Americana,
os 227 nomes dos que morreram na
Primeira Guerra Mundial,
os 514 nomes dos que morreram
na Segunda Guerra,
os 22 nomes dos que morreram
na Guerra da Coreia
e os 37 nomes dos que morreram
na Guerra do Vietnã.
Agora, porque a relação entre as
instituições de elite e os militares
passou a ser o que é hoje depende
de uma série desses fatos
extremamente importantes e
complicados sobre a história dos
EUA.
Basta dizer que a opinião da
maioria dos estudantes de Yale
e de uma boa parte da faculdade de Yale
era que a Guerra do Vietnã
era uma guerra injusta.
E foi por esse motivo
que houve uma falta de vontade por
parte de muitos deles para servir
e, na verdade, uma expressão
corajosa de oposição
por parte de alguns que teve
consequências diretas nas suas vidas.
Mas a atitude de Yale na
Guerra do Vietnã
talvez esteja melhor capturada
nesta imagem de manifestantes
associando esta imagem de algo
usado para a comemoração
daqueles que lutaram numa guerra justa
e usando como uma maneira de expressar
a sua visão de injustiça na guerra
particular disputada no Vietnã.
Para aqueles de vocês que ainda
não estão convencidos
que a filosofia é algo importante:
esse foi um debate filosófico
sobre a natureza do que a
justiça permite.
Independentemente de se os
estudantes de Yale
lutaram na Guerra do Vietnã,
um grande número de
cidadãos norte-americanos
lutaram na Guerra do Vietnã.
E a obra de Jonathan Shay
é uma leitura incrivelmente poderosa
sobre a experiência deles
que justapõe citações da
melhor descrição antiga
sobre a experiência subjetiva da guerra
– o texto fundador, em muitos aspectos,
da tradição literária ocidental,
a Ilíada de Homero –
e as experiências na própria voz
dos veteranos do Vietnã,
com quem Jonathan Shay trabalha num
esforço de ajudá-los a lidar
com o estresse e o trauma produzidos
pela experiência da guerra.
E a tese de Shay neste livro,
como vocês sabem,
é que, quando um líder destrói a
legitimidade da ordem moral
do exército traindo o que
ele chama de themis
– o que é certo, a ordem das coisas,
a estrutura pela qual
podemos entender o mundo
como previsível e bem-ordenado –,
as feridas infligidas sobre os
soldados não são físicas...
Elas são o que Shay chama
de feridas morais.
E essas feridas morais
surgem na Ilíada,
onde Homero descreve as
consequências imediatas e
devastadoras
sobre Aquiles, primeiro no
sentimento de injustiça
por terem tomado o seu
prêmio de guerra e,
depois, por meio do que Shay chama
de comportamento furioso,
resultado da morte do seu
amigo Pátroclo.
Agora, deixa eu fazer uma pausa e
dizer que ao falar sobre isso,
estamos encobrindo
muitas coisas que são
problemáticas nesta história.
Por que Aquiles está chateado?
Ele está chateado porque a
mulher que foi dada a ele
como um prêmio de batalha
será dada a outro homem.
Eu entendo que, para a
maioria de vocês,
a concepção do que a
ordem moral permite
não inclui prêmios de
guerra nesse formato.
E vamos falar mais sobre isso quando
chegarmos à seção de ética.
Como é que vamos dar sentido a
padrões morais que são tratados
como legítimos num
domínio e não em outro?
Mas, por enquanto, eu gostaria
que vocês anotassem aqui,
como na maior parte dos
textos antigos que lemos,
o que vocês acham estranho
e se concentrassem no que
acham familiar.
A descrição da experiência de
Aquiles é algo que soa verdadeira;
e soa verdadeira da mesma forma que a
descrição da experiência
do soldado do Vietnã soa verdadeira.
Shay ressalta que, assim como a Ilíada
é uma história das
consequências devastadoras
para Aquiles e os outros soldados,
as narrativas que os soldados
do Vietnã fornecem
também são um exemplo de algo
que nos força a ver
que as consequências vão além;
e aqui está uma citação da
Ilíada: "a perda da guerra
contra a perda amarga, deixando
demasiados mortos"...
a consequência é manchar a
vida de quem sobrevive.
Um dos maiores males que a Guerra
do Vietnã parece ter feito
para uma boa parte
daqueles que serviram,
voluntariamente ou não,
foi ter produzido neles um
conjunto de sintomas
que alguns psiquiatras descrevem como
transtorno de estresse pós-traumático.
E são sintomas que afetam os soldados,
os sobreviventes do
trauma, em 3 domínios.
Eles afetam as suas ações no mundo,
as suas percepções do mundo
e as suas experiências sociais.
Portanto, um dos sintomas do TEPT é
"uma mobilização persistente do corpo
e da mente em direção ao perigo letal,
um potencial de violência explosiva,
como resultado de estar
sempre em alerta".
Todos vocês conhecem a experiência
de estar totalmente focado
ao sentir-se em perigo.
É algo que ocupa uma porcentagem
enorme de recursos do corpo.
Tudo está enfocado a partir de
respostas imediatas.
E é possível encontrar isso em
todos os tipos de domínios.
Se você estiver envolvido
num jogo de videogame
que exige uma resposta
incrivelmente rápida
ou se você se sentir em algum tipo
de situação de ameaça...
é uma experiência corporal completa
que está relacionada ao mundo
de um jeito particular.
Agora imaginem estar em alerta,
dessa forma, o tempo todo.
Uma das consequências de
estar em estado de alerta
é que as coisas são percebidas do
jeito mais negativo possível.
Se você é uma pessoa
"avessa ao risco",
então você vai, em cada
encontro que tiver,
cogitar a possibilidade de
que você confrontará
o pior cenário possível.
E os soldados que sofrem de TEPT
percebem as coisas ao redor
por meio de mecanismos
elevados de atenção
que vêm com esta ação imediata,
encarando-as como perigos em potencial.
E as coisas que eles perseguem
como perigos em potencial
não são apenas objetos
mundanos do mundo,
como um objeto repousado numa mesa
que pode ser ambiguamente uma arma
ou um pedaço inocente de papelão,
mas também nas suas
interações sociais.
E talvez o maior prejuízo...
e vamos ver o motivo disso
na aula de quinta...
talvez o maior prejuízo seja a
perda da possibilidade
de confiança social.
E quero salientar a vocês a
maneira que isso pode ocorrer
em todas as culturas.
As comunidades que estão sujeitas a
certos tipos de terrorismo
ou guerrilha por opositores
perdem a capacidade de se
comportar humanamente
para aqueles com quem elas lutam.
Se a estratégia do seu oponente
é trazer bombas a seu país
utilizando ambulâncias,
então você vai ser forçado a
tratar as ambulâncias
como objetos suspeitos.
Shay descreve em Achilles
in Vietnam que,
se uma estratégia comum é
colocar um bebê
numa pilha de explosivos, então
você será forçado,
por causa das ações do seu inimigo,
a não ajudar uma criança que precisa.
Roubar do inimigo
essa capacidade de se
comportar de forma humana
é uma estratégia que produz um
ciclo de desordem incrível.
Porque, claro,
apenas uma sensação de estar
encurralado sem opções
é que levaria alguém a tomar a
estratégia de usar ambulâncias
para transportar bombas, e
assim por diante.
A ordem que rege o estado de
guerra convencional
é um reflexo de um certo tipo de
necessidade psicológica.
E a desordem que é típica do estado
de guerra não convencional,
do qual o Vietnã é um exemplo e
o terrorismo é outro,
é algo produzido nas
sociedades como uma espécie
de aproximação do transtorno de
estresse pós-traumático
que Shay identifica nos soldados.
Então o que eu quero fazer agora, nos
últimos 5 minutos de aula,
é dar 2 exemplos do fenômeno
que Shay descreve e,
em seguida, conectá-los com
o desafio de Glauco.
Assim, a Ilíada é um conto
de capricho, de raiva.
E a passagem de abertura do Livro I,
citada por Shay, que eu pedi para hoje,
é uma expressão da raiva
sentida por Aquiles,
indignado com a traição das
regras de honra da guerra.
E Aquiles diz...
isto, na verdade, é uma
citação do Livro XVI,
mas fala sobre o momento anterior.
"Somente esta amargura nutre o meu
coração quando um homem
privou e envergonhou o seu igual,
tomando de volta o seu prêmio
por abuso de poder.
A jovem a quem os aqueus
escolheram para mim,
eu ganhei por minha lança.
Uma cidade com paredes invadida
e saqueada para ela,
então Agamenon roubou-a
das minhas mãos,
como se eu fosse um ignóbil vagabundo."
É uma violação do código de honra.
É uma violação das
regras e expectativas
com que Aquiles entrou nesta guerra.
"Uma cidade com paredes
invadida e saqueada para ela.
Eu estou privado dela, não
pelas regras da guerra,
mas por abuso de poder."
Aqui está um soldado no Vietnã
expressando a mesma coisa.
"Walking point"
– que é uma tarefa que
envolve basicamente ser posto
na linha de frente dos soldados,
podendo ser morto por um explosivo –
"O 'walking point' era um
trabalho extremamente perigoso.
A decisão de quem faria isso
não era tomada de forma justa.
Era tomada politicamente.
Cabia a certas pessoas.
A outras não.
Certas pessoas do lado correto
de certas pessoas."
E essa ideia de que a
distribuição dos perigos não
segue
as regras, segue caprichos,
é desordenadora.
Assim, o resultado disso, e eu já
comentei sobre isso no último slide,
é um tipo de perda de confiança,
um reconhecimento de que objetos comuns
– a história do bebê na mina –
detêm um potencial para o perigo,
nada é o que parece, todas as
certezas se desfazem.
E a 2ª descoberta dos
soldados do Vietnã
é algo que vamos discutir no
contexto de um artigo chamado
"Moral Luck" [Sorte moral].
A descoberta do que se é capaz em
determinadas circunstâncias.
Aqui está o veterano:
"É inacreditável o que os seres
humanos podem fazer uns aos outros.
Eu nunca, em 1 milhão de anos,
pensei que seria capaz de fazer isso.
Nunca, nunca, nunca."
E aqui está a resposta de Shay e
de Homero para Glauco:
Caro Glauco, observe:
A preocupação expressa
por esses soldados
não é sobre o eles que parecem ser.
Não é sobre como eles são
percebidos por terem feito.
De fato, uma das suas queixas é
que, ao chegarem em casa,
ninguém vai ouvir as suas histórias.
A preocupação desses soldados é
sobre o que eles fizeram,
sobre o ser, e não o aparentar.
E é o ser, o que você é, que é
intrinsecamente o caso,
que é motivo de
preocupação para eles.
Abordaremos essa questão no
início da próxima aula
com a discussão sobre Milgram
e depois voltaremos às
leituras de Epicteto
e aos seus análogos de contemporâneos.